before the break we have a Microsoft
speaker to see the blue-eyed speaker the
first hook will be given by the
microphone speaker someone top he's
gonna talk about suppose an algorithm
for simulating the real-time evolution
of music thank you
thanks for the organizers for allowing
me to speak here this is a algorithm for
physicist what's a Hamiltonian
simulation it's a well I'm yeah yeah I
had to quote the
I had to quote the Richard Feynman who
said exactly what I wanted to say if you
want to make a simulation of the nature
that's what that's what this algorithm
is for you'd better make it quick Annika
sure so it will have immediate
applications in all areas of physics I
believe especially when you're
addressing dynamical questions as matter
a pretty particular it also play call
for hydrants physics because we believe
that for field theory has a lattice
regularization which is described by the
lattice Hamiltonian I'll get into what
the Maris Hamiltonian is in a second
and we have seen some application
potential applications in amo physics
where people can manipulate atoms in
their local areas where things become
more or less like a lattice structure it
will have some application of chemical
chemistry I believe although there was a
technical caveat that I will mention in
the later and in a broader perspective
having explanation has been the
subroutine in the in the linear
equations although although we have seen
other algorithms to solve the linear
equation but this was the first in the
first design of the linear equation
solver Hamiltonian simulation was a
routine and if you could cook up some
optimization problem stated as a ground
state finding of a Hamiltonian then the
apparent simulation also becomes a
subroutine of that although in that case
it it is unlikely that your Hamiltonian
will be on a lattice if you allow me to
do one sentence of philosophy the
Hamiltonian simulation is a
manifestation of determinism in physics
you see that your nature is evolving by
the predetermine role and Hamiltonian
simulation does that
so what's the problem input is a local
Hamiltonian strangely my opinion that
computer science community have adopted
little term local humans who mean
completely completely differently in the
computer computer science literature
local Imus when it usually mean without
metric so each Hamiltonian term so is it
you're considering large hermitian
matrix given as a sum of small terms but
each of which acts on a small number of
qubits but there's no distance notion of
distance between the qubits that's the
computer science here's the local
Hamiltonian yes but in that case it is
not so intuitive to think about distance
between qubits I would humbly suggest
that people might have been it would
have been better if people use the low
wave Hamiltonian is that local
Hamiltonian would there wouldn't be a
language barrier between the physicists
the computer science at that problem yes
that's the kind of strange history but
yeah yes so he in this talk in this talk
local Hamiltonian is locality with
respect to a metric space your metric
space is fixed underlying and that
qubits are embedded in that metric space
and we measure locality with respect to
that metric for the technical clarity I
assume that each term acts on the unit
ball a unit sized ball of that year
metric space the output the goal of the
algorithm is to decomposition of this
gigantic unitary the solution of the
Schrodinger equation I have denoted a
solution for the Schrodinger equation as
if the Hamiltonian was time independent
but our algorithm will not really care
about whether is time dependent or
independent
we have my no technical assumption so H
as a matrix a huge matrix so you
shouldn't attempt to write it as a
nice matrix so we stories the
exponentiation of that and obviously the
output should consist of polynomially
many gates in the system size and time
otherwise there's no point of running it
well you may want to implement it but he
will not be efficient Oh
v oh I'm sorry the B was the total
number of qubits and we don't have to
implement this exactly these physis to
approximate it obviously and let me
mention what has been done previously
based on the idea that infinite time
evolutions commute it's the basis of
this this formula if your Hamiltonian
consists of for example two terms for
the sake of simplicity then you can
divide a time into n intervals give all
as if they were commuting operators and
you just repeat and you can show that
error decreases as you increase the n
the rate of that air converges is not
too good so Suzuki in 91 I guess cook up
the formula that gives a better
convergence in terms of N and that's
known as a Suzuki Trotter formula and
recently there has been a rigorous error
analysis using that formula and it has
roughly
volume square dependence there in that
algorithm the time dependence is almost
linear but not quite there's a small
factor and you can you can gain
something by a recent result by
randomizing the order of that and in
2014 which we didn't not realize in the
first version of our paper that there
was a claim that your gate complexity is
not quadratic in the space volume but it
was almost linear but we looked at that
argument that he was tutors
it's arbitrary imager that appears in
the Suzuki order which is implicitly
here yeah it can be made arbitrarily
large in terms of system size dependence
that's that's a constant
yeah the 2014 paper jointly press kill
that argument was tutors that we could
not verify its correctness so I wish it
was right but I'll leave it as it is and
for sparse hermitian matrices which I
which is often called Hamiltonian
there's a Taylor series approach in well
the algorithm itself is a Oracle or
algorithm but if you get down to the
very gate a bottom line the very
down-to-earth gate count then it also
has a volume squared scaling again the
same is true for the technique using
qualm secret processing again you have a
quadratic depends on the volume it is
now V well I kept noticing it's
consisting within this block two to the
N is the matrix size yeah
oh I that these algorithms in the case
of my local Hamiltonian so it is
automatically sparse it is parsley is in
by the locality okay so here's our
result for any now now there it comes
with the technical adjectives we need a
bounded local Hamiltonian bounded means
that each of the Hamiltonian terms in
your Hamiltonian should be uniformly
bounded by some constant which is true
for any reasonable Alerus Hamiltonian in
a time independent case there exists an
algorithm that has depth purely linearly
in D and no dependent almost just dollar
I think logarithmic dependence on the
volume the total gate count is just a
bath time step all of you and it
produces sufficient the approximate
solution where the error dependence is
only logarithmic when it comes to
time-dependent case we should we require
the henna to each each of the individual
Hamiltonian terms should be slowly
varying his time derivative should be
bounded by a some uniform constant and
it the time dependent term should be
efficiently computable otherwise there's
no point of implementing well it becomes
you know quickly too hard to implement
it at some result we have effectively
removed the square dependence of a
previous algorithm with a rigorous error
bounds
and this exponent in the log factor
alpha depends on the some other
subroutine out during an evaluation
later okay the key observation is the
Lee Robinson bounce I'll tell you what
it is there's a absolute light cone in
any reasonable physical system which is
a one of the Assumption the relativistic
theory you assume that there's a light
cone the light speed of light is some
fired number then you build up the
theory in the relativistic theory or in
the nonrelativistic Hamiltonian then
this is this becomes a theorem following
from the locality this is a long history
reaching almost 50 years with increasing
generality so state Mateus night like
this well intuition is this gave me an
operator a supported on some region X
think about just a single speed then I
time evolve that operator in the
Heisenberg picture I conjugate by the
time evolution operator then I let me
call that as a ax of T well since H X
everywhere
generally this operator X everywhere but
not so substantially everywhere but how
not so substantially that's the
statement of this so-called Lee brothers
and bounds the it comes with a plural s
because there are many versions of it
and this is one version so you can take
a commutator of this particular time you
both operator with the untie me not time
you involved operator BY located as some
other spin why it doesn't have to be
single spin but for the sake of
simplicity let me tell you and it's
commutator norm
operator norm is bounded by this
quantity there's a linear linear
dependence of the size of the X you're
you're observing some constant vector
and Zita is a constant that depends on
your lattice dimension and the strength
of your Hamiltonian
he is my evolution time and the most
important parameter L is the distance
between the
two disks at you are that you plug in
your observables in picture it looks
like this so this is a schematic diagram
of this time evolved operator X is right
there you evolve it for time T and then
you want to measure how significant the
operator is there at certain location so
you insert another observer will be and
you compute a commutator and look at
this operator norm then it becomes
exponentially it slightly faster than
exponentially small as you go beyond it
so called light-cone this expression
becomes smaller than one whenever L is
greater than zero T roughly beyond that
point well inside that we don't know
much because the bound is larger than
one but beyond that point it becomes
super explanation small and almost
nothing there it behaves like idea T
over there that's the theorem is about
another version which we will frequently
use is this one if you evolve the same
of some same observable with respect to
the full Hamiltonian H that's one that's
one my operator and I just truncate the
Hamiltonian and evolve under that
so here subscript Omega is just this one
you take the original Hamiltonian and
collect terms only supported on that or
make a region so you can take Omega to
be like disk of this size for example as
you increase the disk size two operators
becomes a similarly singular so L is
well in the in the first person L was
distance between two points now act now
the distance L is distance between the
middle point and the complement of that
vehicle you're considering
any questions about this expression so
obviously this one is a poured upon
Omega nothing beyond that every operator
lives within Omega here you X everywhere
but the difference is very small as long
as your disk is sufficiently large
all your matrices are finite dimensional
matrices what do you mean by
substantially everywhere oh well I mean
just this quantity any operator can be
written as a linear combination of
operators that are local and you can
keep track of the weight of that
operator as you increase the diameter of
that linear component and that linear
component just decreases as you're well
technically yeah yeah yeah yes and no no
because in this all analysis we assume
that the norm of H is bounded however we
do the bound does not depend on the
total system size is uniform so you can
formally take a limit after your take
calculate about
so now what do we do with that we apply
to an algorithm so let's think about the
one dimensional system for the sake of
depicting the situation here's my
spatial coordinate X and this is my time
evolution unitary for time small T time
goes up now I'm gonna approximate it by
this I literally omitted Hamiltonian
terms that acts across the boundary
between two regions a and B H sub little
little H sub a is the sum of terms that
are supported in this block no other
transformation I same is true for B well
this is obviously wrong because I
omitted that how should I fix that well
I can fix like like that I cancelled
what I have done wrong and then inserted
what it was before any question now look
at this now look at this curing operator
that cured my bad guess let me take a
time derivative of that what's this they
say this yeah
just matrix manipulations and you take
components from here that because this
and you you your H will be kick out of
that
it's a straightening equation nothing
more now I insert another resolution my
identity so this is indeed equality here
now look at this part
this is a hermitian operator where you
only have terms in the between the
boundary across the boundary nothing
else all the terms in the entirely in a
or entirely B are cancelled off so this
is this acts on the somewhere here it is
conjugated by a unitary which happens to
be a time evolution operator of H sub a
plus a sub B it's a local operator
evolved by local Hamiltonian or some
time T so we can apply our previous lee
robinson bound and conclude that this
overall thing the the thing in the red
box is almost local it is almost
supported on this bound around that
boundary okay and with respect to that a
local operator which happens to be a
hermitian operator and now the whole
equation looks like the Schrodinger
equation for this unitary with respect
to this local hermitian matrix
yeah he says training equation so that's
the all time derivative of unitary
equals hermitian operator times original
unitary
okay yes I just copied the previous
equation and now look at this hermitian
operator more carefully applying the
previous live robinson bound where now
we I just plug in H I substitute H with
H a plus a sub B then the bound says is
it's okay to truncate that part because
yeah I took Megha to be from here to
there and the approximation error
depends on though on the size of this L
and that's exponentially small as long
as L is greater than this in a solution
of that equation by looking at the
structure is immediately this I'm doing
all the calculations that you need here
so please practice original Hessian
matrix by the virtue of leap robinson
bound i can truncate it with making a
very small error that is exponentially
small in that distance now I solve this
equation but the solution of that is by
the same by off surfing it's it's just
this so I started with the full time
evolution operator approximately with
the wrong thing cured that now I have
solved this part by looking at more
carefully I could I was able to truncate
that so I'm left with this yes yes and
this error is precisely this one that is
small in that exponentially in that
distance well I don't have to do that
right so we have a approximate equality
between full Hamiltonian evolution
operator versus something that is much
more smaller the virtue of this
decomposition well this I mean
vision is that every block is a
Hamiltonian evolution operator where
it's not a strange transformation you
just collect the terms that are
supporting in that block nothing more
very simple okay so start the waiting
again I have to compose this but nothing
stops me from looking at this one so I
could do this one well this is
reflection symmetric I can keep doing
and end up with this diagram now the
approximate error becomes obviously
additively worsen but it's only is only
linear in the number of decompositions
remember the air was exponentially small
in that distance effectively the overlap
length has to be proportional to the
so-called liberals and velocity times
the time and air dependence is only
logarithmic and we chose time to be just
unit okay yeah that's the that's the
that's pretty much the algorithm now
your problem is reduced to focusing on
that small block how small lower it's
making the number of qubits and they
lowered me in the owner Epsilon so your
problem gets explanation small how do we
go to higher dimensions that was the
argument was on the one mission but
higher dimensional is pretty easy you
could do in either what what for the
first naive approach is to think of a
higher dimension as a collection of
hyperplanes then you do iteratively by
induction in d the dimension but there's
here's a clever more clever way the
one-dimensional situation we observed
that the decomposition was based on the
fact that the one-dimensional line was
two colorable raining blue-green
Brooklyn brew the one-dimensional line
is two colorable and the algorithm was
evolved to color little by for
intercession by backward and the other
color by
or the two in two dimensions you can
find a colorable decomposition using
only three not not four
if you if you consider the two dimension
plane is a union of hyper planes that
you would have have done this three
times three so nine step will be
required but in this step you only mean
if I in three three dimensions you can
find the decomposition or tessellation
of your lattice using four colors so in
general in d dimensions or in any
lattice that is alpha colorable then you
only need two alpha minus 1 layers of
such small unitary
how do we implement small blocks well
for that part we don't do have to do
anything thanks to the previous work but
let's check the requirements the block
size is only that much we were going to
repeat just T times a number of blocks
is at most the space-time volume so each
block the the air in the in that
decomposition should be as good as one
over the space-time volume multiplied by
the overall accuracy you want in the end
so each block size is log of space-time
volume divided by accuracy and each
block has to be decomposed to further
down to the elementary gate with another
error parameter epsilon that is bounded
by that provided this then the overall
unit area will be good to absolutive
difference so the 4k count will be the
number of these blocks times the cost of
each block where the size is that much
and the desired accuracy is that
and there is a patient algorithm for
that those dependencies on only
polynomial in the space-time volume and
accuracy so you can use it or whatever
you want
yeah this is I think I'm repeating third
time this morning but for the sake of
completeness let me just mention that
any Hamiltonian can be written as a
linear combination by expressing them as
a poly matrices or if you are
hamiltonian fermionic then make it
Jordan bringing transformation and
represent them as oh yeah I will mention
the formula in case later there are some
special subtlety then using the Olivia
oblivious amplitude amplification or
using a signal processing you can
achieve exponential accuracy
and we have done some you Merisi if it's
really has a small constant as well and
it turns out that well it's not so bad
for some very small system size is
specialized where general purpose our
algorithm tends to perform better but at
a multi system size like a hundred spins
it asymptotically better once wins out
the particular model was the Heisenberg
model subject to random magnetic field
and the accuracy was set to this number
and the time we called was proportional
to persistence times you can do this
gate count very elementary accounts
using our development kit it gives you
the full decomposition into a circuit to
not remember that but I believe it was
like a sixth order or something it
wasn't my first order up to thirty or so
and then six
and our algorithm is optimal
it's another simple back fact but worth
mentioning of course
so first observation any circuit is a
time evolution because if you lay down
every elementary unit area then unit
area is an exponential of some hermitian
matrix that's it so if you allow time
dependents in your Hamiltonian that is
piecewise constant then every circuit is
eight kind of time-dependent Hamiltonian
evolution it is local so now we we need
to be just count how many functions can
a circuit Express given a layout of that
resembles Hamiltonian simulation we
divide the full system into
logarithmically sized blocks and we just
count the number of functions that
resize it within that block and it's
going to be doubly exponential in the
block size but since size is it's only
logarithmic function number of functions
for each column is exponential in time
there are n such well research columns
so roughly it is exponential in the
space time volume there is a and that
count does not really decrease even if
you map all the functions to map into a
binary bit you may think it is not that
trivial bit
so take the parity of each column that
will lose some information from the
individual functions but one minor
constraint on the function tells you
that you can individually need read off
the function namely that you require the
function to be assumed zero for a
particular integral say of zero and the
cancellation law holds and the function
count doesn't really decrease
this is the reason we consider that your
binary valued function is because to to
answer the following question I want
Hamiltonian evolution but I do not care
about the whole wave function what if I
just demand for the expectation value of
a single spin of some local observable
can we speed up in that situation the
answer is the answer is going to be no
and the reason is that even if you
require such a single observable the
number of functions that is expressible
pointing to that local observable is
still exponentially large in space-time
volume so yeah that's the circuit on the
qubits can express X many many boolean
functions and any general Hamiltonian
simulation algorithm should be able to
capture all such functions and if you if
you're a quantum algorithm generates a G
number of gates then that circuit can
only express exponentially many
functions therefore the number of kids
must be linear in space-time volume
again this bound is is how hoes only if
even if you only require a single bit
output in the end as long as your time
evolution time is larger than your gold
and in the endeavor to this work we
pushed scope of the Robinson bound a
little bit further now it becomes
unbounded well in the technical sense so
previous liberalism bad all assumed well
except for one work all assume that each
term should be uniformly bounded in norm
we relaxed that we just require that
them to be finite we don't care about
how fine that it is but we require the
commutator is bounded uniformly
and the result is under that assumption
without the uniform bound on the
hamiltonian norm the interaction
strength the functional form is pretty
much the same you get the dependence on
the commutator about by a square root
but that's it as long as this is finite
this is finite functional form on L is
the same as before
previous results in this setting assume
that you had two types of terms that are
translated to each other by relators
so this is my summary your local
Hamiltonian simulation problem is as
efficient it can be the we our quantum
circuit has the same number of gate
counts as your space-time volume would
have in the the reason but never the
reason is that the local interaction
implies not generate correlation too
fast in the quantitatively
Lele Robison bounds technique gives us a
natural decomposition and we just plug
in generic purpose matrix exponentiation
algorithms with an exponential accuracy
to achieve almost I didn't talk about
the fermion at all however I should
mention that we can it does cover the
fermion formula Hamiltonian system the
lee robinson bound induced the
composition does not care whether it is
for immune or boson or spin doesn't
matter but the small block
implementation may be affected by the
fact that you are working with a fermion
because of the long potentially long
Jordan beginner stream but there is a
way or get a there's a way to get around
this due to the first rather and say
rough from 2005 I can tell you if you
ask and we have shown that space-time
the linear gate count is optimal up to
lower three factors because boost means
basically everything
one open problem that would excite
physicists would be can we can we
improve the algorithm for low energy
sectors local Hamiltonian you write down
on a piece of paper typically covers two
high energies as well which we which
faces don't care about so in a sense
it's well if such a nagger exists it's
like doing the renormalization group
full or automatically has yet to be
found this is the key figure that I
would like you to remember the
competition for backward for time
evolution well it is a big statement but
what what's RG it's so you you are
provided with the Hamiltonian that would
describe very high energy as well as the
very low energy but if you so that's
what our G flow calculation does you
focus on the low energy sector and you
can you truncate your three degrees of
freedom so that transformation within
that subspace only get you in the low
energy subspace and you derive that
effective Hamiltonian we didn't a
subspace so you calculate you you're
provided with big giant Newtonian but
you reduce the Hilbert space and compute
another Hamiltonian that would
approximate the original one that is in
the approximation would valid only in
the low energy sector it's very hard to
make it rigorously there are a lot of
heuristics that works amazingly well in
practice
also for dynamics yeah well typically
example is the Kwan chemistry reason
yeah we believe that the standard model
describes physics including on the
electrolyte dynamics
and the weak forces strong forces and so
on but it produces the Coulomb
interaction at the low energy that we
typically experience and their
Hamiltonian is no more long local its
long range in the sense that the
potential decreases what has 1 over R
that is absent in the standard model
[Music]
I'm attorney instead location too long I
know that there were works on so if you
have a power-law decay of interaction
strength then you do get some kind of
liberalism bound but the dependence on
the distance separation is no more
exponential it's slightly it's likely I
think it's worse than the originally
international range so correspondingly
their air defenses gets bad and the your
gate complex will go up
it is wonderful respect to the previous
question so is one formulation of this
last question whether you could have so
in general when you ask for these
simulation producing reaction of the
unitary the whole unitary mobile space
of to operate and all that works in some
sectors but right and you said there's
some mistakes
oh yeah businesses have done that
calculation for a long time but it often
involves very heuristic cutting of
infinities they are kept little piece of
paper yes interaction
yeah yeah yeah my solution was in the
international picture yes
can we use your counting argument
basically in terms of the accessibility
also for this case for this case yes so
I do not expect that space-time ball
independence would go away it should
still be there however well I'm asking
well here's another parameter the energy
scale so energy in the typical
Hamiltonian system is proportional to a
space volume right now you demand that
for low so can that factor be counted
for some potential with them
can you comment on the four yes sure
so one-dimensional fermion case is kind
of degenerate so there's no issue in
that is all the old your Jordan beginner
string will cancel out
but in the two dimensions you gotta
order your firm is in some way and one
naive way is just this this snake
pattern and imagine that you had a
interaction term like this I see J and
your Jordan finger string will have
something like so generally you're the
your local operator in your Hamiltonian
that you thought was local now is not
local anymore and because the these
operators are overlapping with each
other so in the implementing small
blocks you cannot you can no longer do
it simultaneously and you have to do it
separately and it boosts up your this
death by a factor of system science we
want to avoid that how do we do that
first rather 0 2005 consider the
following trick insert auxilary permian
say gamma 1 - well you got to insert
that for these ocular apartment on every
side and then so if your hamiltonian
term was like something like this you
consider you just change your
hamiltonian term like this one now it
has even number of affirming operator on
that line so all this Jordan being a
string will cast love and the
representation of this operator in the
Cupid basis will be still local and
gamma1 gamma2 the product is still
commuting with this transformed
hamiltonian so you don't have to do
anything you just initialize those
Cupid's in the some some state and will
still therefore for the entire symptom
simulation algorithm so that's the trick
[Applause]